[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
FRED TURNER: Thanks, guys.
Great to see you here.
Thank you for coming out.
Appreciate it, especially
on a beautiful day.
You could be out
walking the campus.
It's great to have you here.
I'm really excited to be
here, partly because I think
we're standing or sitting in
a place that has a history
that we tend not to know.
And that's the history I
want to bring you today.
I'm going to make a case that
goes through three points.
Probably speak for
about 40 minutes.
If you have questions of
fact as I move through that,
please jump right in.
For more conceptual
stuff, maybe hold it.
We'll have plenty
of time for Q&A.
And I want to start with
the problem of Facebook.
Not as competition, but
as a historical problem.
Where did this strange
form of sociability,
architecture-enabled
sociability come from?
And where did the hope that by
using these digital systems,
we might become more
individuated, more expressive,
more collaborative begin?
To answer that
question, I'm going
to turn back to World War II
and the birth of a media form
that I've ended up calling
the democratic surround.
And it's a funny time.
In a nutshell, World War II,
terrible fear that mass media,
one-to-many media--
television, film, newspapers,
and the like--
actually turn us into fascists.
And there's different ways
people think it happens,
but they really
think it happens.
And so the question at the start
of World War II for Americans,
in government, in
law, in journalism
is, how can we do propaganda
in a way that will not make
our citizens authoritarians?
It turns out that
one of the answers
is creating multiple media.
You begin to imagine a
world of multiple images,
multiple sounds,
surrounding individuals who
are then presumed to be free.
My argument will be that that
turn during World War II shaped
the '60s, shaped the
multimedia, especially
the psychedelic
multimedia of the 1960s.
And brought us ultimately,
the social media of today.
There's a big jump from
the '60s to social media.
That's the subject from
another book I've done,
but we'll go there anyways.
So that's where
we're headed today.
So let's start with Facebook.
So Facebook is many things.
And in this room, I don't need
to get into the technology
of it at all.
But in some ways, Facebook is
a vision of a particular style
of sociability.
It's technology-enabled.
It's individualistic.
You speak often
as an individual.
You can do things
collaboratively
and collectively.
But it's a kind of tool-enabled,
expressive individualism.
And in many ways,
the sort of building
of a platform world
in which we could
act independently
and individually
was meant to help us be free.
When I came into academia
about 15 years ago,
I was told that what you need
to do to have a democracy
is you need to
decentralize media.
And a lot of the folks who
founded Facebook and Google
very much saw themselves,
I think in the early days,
as building decentralized
media forms that
were ultimately pro-democratic.
I would argue that the
rise of Donald Trump
gives the lie to the sense
that decentralized media always
need to produce democratic,
anti-authoritarian techniques.
But we'll come back
to that in a moment.
Suffice to say that
Facebook represents
a world of multi-screen
sociability,
individual,
expressive-enabled style.
It's both commercial
and personal.
And it's controlled
and managed--
and this is the central
point, especially here,
through processes of
aggregation, nudging,
and architecture.
It's a space that's
managed through design.
And you all know this
better than most,
it's not a space where
people negotiate contracts
with each interaction.
On the contrary,
they use a tool.
They do something.
They do something together,
something else happens.
And that interaction is
structured architecturally.
The question I want
to address today
is, how did we get
to a place where
that architectural
management of individuals
was perceived as a
pro-democratic operation?
A little bit of background.
So I've been an academic
for about 15 years.
I was a journalist beforehand,
as Dave pointed out.
And in that time, I've been
tracking the integration
of computing and computing
technology, computing culture,
engineering culture
into American culture
more broadly after World War II.
I am a perverse
creature in many ways.
But in one in particular.
I'm kind of an
engineering fanboy.
I know it's an odd thing, right?
But I am a scholar who
is not an engineer,
but who studies engineers.
And who thinks
they are ultimately
the agents of
cultural change that
are among the most important
in our particular historical
moment.
And so that's what
I've been studying.
I've been studying
different visions
of engineering, different
visions of engineering culture.
I started with this book
here, "From Counterculture
to Cyberculture," which
is a book about Stewart
Brand and the "Whole
Earth Catalog"
and a group of
countercultural figures
who really shaped what we
thought the internet would be.
They brought us some of the
following terms-- virtual
community, electronic frontier.
You'll know John Perry
Barlow just died.
And my personal favorite,
personal computer.
So I wrote that book.
And I was here at Stanford.
And you know, when
I wrote that book,
I was told that the 1960s were
a revolution against everything
connected to the
1940s and the '50s.
The '40s and the '50s
were black and white,
Cold War, locked down, very much
a kind of containment culture.
And what I found when
I went to interview
these folks from the '60s
was that on the contrary.
They were reading
all this literature
from the '40s and '50s.
They were reading Margaret Mead.
They were reading Erich Fromm.
They were reading psychologists.
They were reading engineers.
They were reading
Norbert Wiener.
And the question I had was, why?
And so I went back in
time, and I wrote a prequel
to that book called "The
Democratic Surround."
And that's the book I'll
be talking about today.
All right, back to the past.
Welcome to 1938, a
time of great fear.
No one here was alive in '38,
but I've spent a lot of time
back in that timeframe.
And at the start of World War
II, Americans faced a problem.
We looked across the ocean,
and we looked at Germany.
Germany was, we thought, the
most cultured nation in Europe.
They brought us Beethoven.
They brought us Gerta, the poet.
They brought us all kinds
of great engineering.
How was it that
they had fallen head
over heels for this crazy,
short, mustachioed dictator,
Adolf Hitler?
How did that happen?
OK.
So nobody really knows.
Today, we might say
it's because there
was all this chaos in Weimar,
Germany after World War I.
But at the time,
most Americans--
intellectuals, journalists,
folks in Roosevelt's circle
said, nope.
You know what it?
It was the mass media.
Mass media.
Radio, film, the newspaper,
literally turned Germany
into an authoritarian nation.
There were two theories
about how it happened.
One, which is one of my
special favorites, is--
this is the picture of Hermann
Goring designed to show it.
Was that Nazi leadership
was actually crazy.
So there are people who actually
thought, the Nazi leaders,
they're all just actually
clinically insane.
And something about
mass media has
let them transmit their
madness into our minds.
OK, fine.
That's one theory.
Now remember, this is
only 15 years after Freud
has come to America.
So there's a sort of--
suddenly, everybody's
interested in the unconscious.
And everybody is
thinking, well, we've
got this unconscious space,
which they tended to think
was down here.
I don't know why.
But the unconscious is
somewhere down in here.
And somehow, media
moved past your brain
and invoke your unconscious.
This takes us to
the second theory.
The second theory is that media
themselves are so powerful,
just in themselves that they--
by virtue of the fact that
they are what they are,
turn off your reason.
You can't think when
your mind is on media.
That's the theory.
And when you can't
think, you can't reason.
You can't defend
yourself with reason.
And so you become
prey to a series
of desires coming
from your unconscious
to be attached to a leader.
And I thought you might
enjoy this picture.
This is from a poster from 1937.
It's meant to show how radio
is reaching even the smallest
houses in the farthest
plains of America.
But you can see by the
thickness of these arrows,
they look a little bit more
like bombers coming in.
Like, radio is going
to bomb the prairie.
And there's a fear
of these media.
This is how bad the fear got.
Here's Franklin Roosevelt.
Give you a little context.
If you run with
American historians,
as I do, and you say to
an American historian
of the 20th century, what's
the most important thing that
happened in the 20th century?
They get kind of misty-eyed
and they say, Roosevelt.
They do.
They really do.
And imagine my surprise when I
went back and started reading
magazines from this period and
saw Franklin Roosevelt referred
to as the fourth fascist.
This is "The Saturday
Evening Post," right?
Franklin Roosevelt was
the father of democracy,
at least in the 20th century.
Why was he called
the fourth fascist?
Well, he was called that
alongside Tojo, Hitler,
and Mussolini.
Because people feared that
through his fireside chats,
he was finding a way to use mass
media to emotionally manipulate
American audiences into
believing that they, too,
should centralize the state.
Remember, this is the
era when he's trying
to rebuild the American state.
They thought he
was trying to build
a centralized American
state around an American
dictatorial-style leader.
And they were terribly
afraid that he
was able to take
his personality,
move it through the media, and
convince people to follow him.
And at that time, the fear of
fascism wasn't unreasonable.
We forget this.
I knew nothing of this until
I started doing this book.
1939, Madison Square
Garden, 22,000 Americans
rallied for fascism.
For fascism.
They rallied under
a banner that said
"stop Jewish domination
of Christian America."
1939, after Hitler
went into Poland,
after Hitler
marched into Poland,
1,000 Americans marched
down East 86th Street
in brown shirts of their own
making, faux-Nazi uniforms,
carrying swastika flags and
American flags together.
Crowds gathered and
watched and did not boo.
They were not booed.
Simply astonishing.
I just couldn't believe this.
OK.
So Humphrey Bogart.
Everybody here has seen
Humphrey Bogart movies?
OK.
I'm sorry, this is the
audience interaction part
of our event today.
OK.
So tell me the name of a
Humphrey Bogart movie you know?
AUDIENCE: "Casablanca."
FRED TURNER: "Casablanca."
Good.
AUDIENCE: "Maltese Falcon."
FRED TURNER: "Maltese Falcon."
Keep going.
Pardon?
You can use your
phone if you have to.
All right.
Well, that's pretty good.
"Maltese Falcon."
"Key Largo."
Was is it, "Key West?"
I forget.
It's "Key Largo."
I'm guessing that
none of you have ever
heard of a movie called
"The Black Legion."
I had never heard of this.
I had insomnia one night.
I woke up in the
middle of the night
and I'm watching this movie
called "The Black Legion"
where Humphrey Bogart is a
black-shirted American fascist
who kills his Polish neighbor
because his Polish neighbor has
taken his job.
This is 1937 in America.
That's a very
popular movie in '37.
And it's interesting.
We never talk about
it now, but there
was a terrible fear
in the late '30s
that fascism could happen here.
If it had happened in
Germany, it could happen here.
You can even see here
in the late '30s,
these are British fascists
giving the fascist salute
in the late '30s in England.
My point is that fascism is
a viable option in the United
States in that period.
We tend not to remember it.
And this poses a very
serious challenge
for American intellectuals
and government officials.
How is it that we're
going to be able to make
a unified America that can fight
against fascism without turning
our citizens into
authoritarians?
What kind of media
can we design?
And what kind of personality
should they have?
OK.
We have to have one brief,
very deeply academic digression
here.
Bear with me.
OK.
So dominant idea in
this period comes
from something called culture
and personality anthropology.
This was a theory that dominated
early 20th century American
anthropology, that every culture
had its own natural personality
style.
And that your family
raised you into that style.
So an effective family helped
you adjust your personality,
whatever it was, to the
personality of your culture,
such that you were able
to move easily within it.
Media continued that work
once you left the family.
So one of the theories
running around
about how Germany
became authoritarian
was that there was a kind
of authoritarian personality
style in German culture
that matched up very
nicely to the way that
mass media worked.
The question then
became in America,
what is an American
personality style?
What is a democratic
And how can we create a
medium that will produce one?
So inside Roosevelt's
circle, there's
a group of folks who
say that doesn't matter.
We need to do what
Goebbels is doing,
Hitler's propaganda minister.
We need to go ahead, turn our
citizens into authoritarians,
call it a day.
We'll deprogram them later.
There's another group though,
led by Margaret Mead and an art
historian named Arthur Upham
Pope, and Gregory Bateson,
social scientists of the
mid-century, who say,
no, wait a minute.
That's actually disastrous.
We can't do that.
We cannot turn our
people into Germans.
We have to be Americans.
And we have to have found
a way of being together
around a democratic
mode of being.
We have to think about what
a democratic personality is,
an American
personality, and we need
to build a medium that will help
people be unified in that idea.
This is Gordon Allport.
He's a member of the Committee
for National Morale charged
with doing this.
The Committee for
National Morale
is a group of 60 American
social scientists
who are advisors to
Roosevelt. They write books.
They're very visible.
He writes this
funny essay in 1942
called "The Nature of
Democratic Morale."
It's remarkably prescient.
There are two words that I
want to flag for you here.
The first word is "personality."
In this period, it
is the personality
that is the center of
resistance to fascism.
Something about
your inner psyche
is the way that you're
going to resist fascism.
The other word here
that's really important
is "coordination."
Fascism with a top-down,
bureaucratic, one-to-many way
of living and being.
A democratic mode
of organizing would
have to be nonhierarchical.
It would have to
be collaborative.
It would have to be a
coordination mechanism.
I hope you're beginning to
hear the word "Facebook."
Because this is where the
dream of a kind of coordination
mechanism for free
individuals is born.
It's right here.
All right.
So good news and bad news.
The good news is that the
Committee for National Morale
wants to save America.
The bad news is they don't
know how to make media.
They're just
sociologists, mostly.
They really have no clue.
Lucky for them, they're
in New York at a moment
when a group of Bauhaus artist
refugees have just arrived.
And these guys know how
to make media like crazy.
One of them is Herbert Bayer.
Do any of you work with
type design here at Google?
OK.
If you're a type
designer here, you
are working with
Herbert Bayer's tools.
Herbert Bayer developed
an all-lowercase typeface
that is frequently used
at Google, actually.
Another thing that he
did was he developed
an exhibition style called the
360 degree field of vision.
All right.
Totally wacky to be
thinking about politics
in terms of exhibition
design, but really important.
When he develops this in
the mid-'30s, almost every
exhibition you go to
has a single picture.
You look at it.
You move along.
Single picture,
eye-level, move along.
What he says is no.
That's hierarchical.
That's domineering.
What we need is to surround
people with images,
surround them with
sounds, and let
them choose the
images and sounds that
are most meaningful to them
and stitch them together
into their own personality.
Only through this
process of integrating
multiple information sources
can people be free and whole.
Again, this is starting to
sound a little bit like Larry
and Sergey in the
early days, I hope.
Just a little bit.
That integration piece.
In Germany, before
he comes over,
this is to help people
resist the pressures
of industrialization.
When he comes to the US,
he desperately needs work.
He says, oh, this is how you
make a democratic character.
And almost immediately,
he's designing
propaganda environments.
This is the first one.
1942, this is a
museum exhibition
at the Museum of
Modern Art in New York.
And it is meant to be a
surround, a space in which
people walk through and see
giant images, small images,
and integrate those images
into their own imaginations.
A couple of things
about this space.
To our own eyes, it might
look not very original.
Big picture, small
pictures, no big deal.
In the time that it was
made, that's a very big deal.
Museums didn't do this.
Second thing that's
important is we can clearly
see the manipulative
propagandistic intent.
This is Pearl Harbor.
This is a farmer.
It says war.
They asked for it.
Now, by the living
God, they'll get it.
Here is Tojo giggling
in the bottom.
To an America that's
just been attacked,
this is pretty straight-up
propagandistic.
If you stand in
this corner, you're
going to get pretty furious.
But people didn't
perceive it that way.
They didn't perceive that
they were domineered.
On the contrary, they
really enjoyed the sense
that they could walk through the
exhibition at their own pace,
making sense of it in the
ways that they wanted to.
And I want to read you what
some of the reviewers said.
Here's the guy from
"New York Times."
He says, "I think that no
one can see this exhibition
without feeling that he is a
part of the power of America.
It is this inescapable
sense of identity.
The individual spectator
identifying himself
with the whole that makes
the event so moving."
My favorite is a reviewer
from Springfield, Illinois.
She says, "Road to
Victory does not
mold the visitors'
opinions, for that word
smacks of the fascist concept
of dominating men's minds."
The key point here is
that this exhibition
marries the search for
a democratic personality
to a design for
multi-image environments.
That combination
is what I'm calling
the democratic surround.
It's a combination
that informs how
we think about the design of
digital environments today.
How did we get there?
Well, there are lots
of ways forward.
And I won't take you
through all of them.
But essentially,
this design feature,
this form that I've
just described,
moves from World War II
to the '60s in two ways.
One, through a whole slew
of propaganda expositions
overseas that are
designed to change
the minds of our potential
allies or enemies.
And the other through
a series of art worlds.
This is what the propaganda
worlds looked like.
This is the first of them.
1956, Kabul, Afghanistan.
That's a dome designed
by Buckminster Fuller.
And inside, it's got
a whole slew of images
as well as of a mock TV
station, for whatever reason.
OK.
So here's this really
painful archival moment.
So I'm at the United States
Information Agency Archives
in Maryland, near
Washington, DC.
And I found a declassified
document about this program.
It said, our job, as
information specialists,
is to act like therapists.
We need to first assess
the psychological condition
of foreign peoples, i.e.
How democratic are they?
We then need to build a media
environment in which they
can experience
choice, collaboration
in a democratic mode.
And then we need to test
to see if it worked.
This is the environment.
This is the test.
It was early days.
Afghan visitors were shown these
pictures as they left the dome
and asked, which one
characterized their response
to the dome most effectively?
Yeah, I know.
This is kind of like, Really?
I mean, I don't even
know what these mean.
I got these images
from the guy who was
in charge of the whole program.
He showed me these pictures.
I don't know what they mean.
He doesn't know what
they mean either anymore.
I think the one on the
left is meant to be
sort of shock and surprise.
The one on the right, ha-ha.
I feel all warm.
The middle one?
I don't know.
It's almost stereotypes.
OK.
So that wasn't very
sophisticated, but this was.
This was 1959, the American
National Exposition in Moscow.
This is where the kitchen debate
between Khrushchev and Nixon
took place.
It took place down
to the right there.
And this is a gigantic
geodesic dome, glittering gold,
created by Buckminster
Fuller with seven TV screens,
each showing a different
still image created
by Ray and Charles
Eames, the designers.
This was meant to be
an environment that
showed Russians that we had a
diverse array of experiences.
Russians were meant
to enter this space,
see multiple images,
knit those images
into their own experience,
and to understand that America
was a place of choice.
And it's kind of
funny, because--
well, I'll tell you a
little more in a minute.
This is what it looked like
when you entered that building.
Those are the screens up above
showing images of America.
A bit of the Family of Man
exhibition down to the right.
And those are Soviet
citizens in the middle.
What's intriguing
about this space
is that it wasn't just a
space for the persuasion
of Soviet citizens
to enjoy choice.
It was also a place of
intensive monitoring.
So this is a RAMAC
computer supplied by IBM
with a Russian translator.
It was preprogrammed to answer
4,000 questions about America.
To print out the answers
to 4,000 questions.
The way that it was
supposed to work
was that the Soviet citizens
would go and ask the translator
a question.
He would somehow key
it into the machine.
The machine would
print out an answer,
and he would translate it back.
The thing that the machine
did that I love best though--
I'm sure you can already
guess what it did.
It recorded the questions.
And this is really important.
Because in this period,
America doesn't actually
know much about what the
Soviet Union is doing.
We really don't know anyone.
I was raised playing war
with my little soldiers.
The soldiers were always
Russians and Americans.
Very powerful.
In addition to this
computer system,
there were 20
Russian-speaking translators
stationed around the space.
They, too, were busy recording
the questions that they
were asked and reporting
them back to their handlers
at the end of every day.
Great records were kept of the
different American products
that were available
that people stole.
They wanted to see which
things people stole
to see which things
they really wanted.
I mean, this is the most
carefully-tracked exposition
ever created.
It's a wonderful thing to
study because every document
connected to it is available.
They took every
single press clipping
from around the
Soviet Union in Europe
and collected it into a file.
So for a guy like me,
this is manna, right?
This is just pure heaven.
I can just show up
and there it all is.
And it really was
an incredible thing.
But the thing I want
to flag is that this
is an environment built out
of Herbert Bayer's designs
that they hope will allow
people to experience
democratic choice
under conditions
of pervasive surveillance.
So that environmental model
also travels into the '60s
through the art world.
This is John Cage.
John Cage is a composer and a
pianist from the mid-century.
He's often thought
to have been a sort
of psychedelic
countercultural figure.
And he was.
He was also a great patriot.
I'll say more about
that in a moment.
He's most famous for
a composition called
"4 minutes and 33 Seconds" in
which the following occurred.
Guy goes to a piano, sits down
at the piano, and doesn't play.
And in the not playing,
according to Cage,
allowed the audience to hear
the sounds that surrounded them
in the room.
Cage was someone who actually
studied with the Bauhaus
figures who brought us
the visual designs I
showed earlier.
And he ended up teaching with
them at Chicago for a year.
And when he did, he
absorbed their theories
of the semiotic surround.
Their theories of surrounding
people with sounds.
And he would go on to compose
pieces-- compose isn't
even quite the right word.
He would go on to
challenge chords.
Go on to challenge harmony.
Say no, what we need
to do is help people
experience random sounds.
One of the places that he
did that most effectively, it
was a place called
Black Mountain College.
Black Mountain College
in the late '50s
was the home of the avant-garde
art world in America.
And it was also the
home of democracy.
I was really lucky.
I found in the archives,
a summer class schedule
from one of the students
in the 1952 summer session.
Here's what they did.
They had six teachers.
Music with John Cage, dance
with Merce Cunningham,
who's over there on the right.
Painting with Willem de Kooning.
Architecture with
Buckminster Fuller.
Talk about a line-up.
This is your weekly class
list, like unbelievable.
In addition, they
were required to take
a course in culture and
personality anthropology
and the workings of
the United Nations.
Weird combo, right?
The theory at the time was
that if we can surround people
with the arts and individual
creativity and encourage it,
and if we can help them build
new architectures to sustain
these new modes
of collaboration--
geodesic domes, performances.
And if we can give them the
political theory of democracy
that we use at the
UN, they can literally
model first in their
own lives, and then
build a world that
looks that way.
And so the summer of 1952,
Cage, Fuller, Cunningham,
they gather together and
they stage what at the time
was called the First Happening.
It's the wackiest event, right?
Nobody really knows
what happened.
But something like this.
A group of artists enter a room.
There's a bunch of chairs.
People sit down in the chairs.
Somebody climbs a
ladder and reads a poem.
A dog runs through the room.
Somebody plays the piano.
At the end, the artists all
get out teacups and put them
on the empty chairs.
End of performance.
It's like, OK.
I first read that.
I was like, why did they
think this was so important?
This seems kind of nuts.
On what world is this important?
In retrospect, it
was hugely important.
They were demonstrating in
their performance of the arts
that, in fact, you
could surround people
with visual images, strange
bits of performance,
fragments of experience, and
they could make sense of those
and become whole people.
That idea traveled
directly into the 1960s
through John Cage's work.
Cage went to New York
in the late '50s,
taught musical
composition to a series
of artists who went on to
build multi-image environments,
multimedia environments
like this one.
This is from the Us Company.
It's a shrine.
And you are meant
to enter it and have
the experience of being
united with people
around the globe in
your imagination.
You are imagined to be all one.
You are imagined to
share consciousness
with those folks who
are all around you.
How many of you have
been to Burning Man?
Oh, my.
There's a new generation at
Google today, isn't there?
That's interesting.
OK.
Pause for a riff.
When I first came to
Google, the very first time
I came to these offices, I
went to building 42 or 43.
I forget, whichever the main
check-in room was at the time.
And the lobby was
entirely decorated
in images of Burning Man.
Not so much anymore.
Yeah, interesting.
OK.
So the burners have been
looking at this stuff.
OK.
And it's really interesting.
It's a psychedelic
environment designed
to help you imagine yourself
as a new kind of person.
Very technology-driven.
Very much designed and meant
to be an expressive space.
But also, something designed to
produce a new kind of person.
It was called by journalists
at the time a "Be-In"
because you were meant to be in
the space and experience a new
way of being together.
And this was the
poster for that event.
What I want you to see is this
expression, we are all one.
We are all one.
Very much a '60s thing.
But also, very
much a '40s thing.
Very much a kind of
we've won World War II,
universal humanist way
of looking at the world.
This is what it could be.
So if you look at the
'60s, you could say, wow,
what a happy ending to
the story of the '40s.
We started with mass
media, fascism, hierarchy,
sort of rigid manipulation
of people through mass media.
And now in the '60s, we end
up at something like the 1967
human Be-In in San Francisco,
where people paint their faces.
They dance.
Rock and roll bands play.
Janis Joplin is there.
Beat poets are there.
It looks like a
great liberation.
I should say, I'm famous
in my academic circles
for always ending on a downer.
I'm going to try really hard
not to end on a downer today.
All right.
So on the one hand, if you think
about the democratic surround
as an alternative to mass
media, as an alternative
to top-down, authoritarian,
one-to-many media,
it looks pretty good.
If you think about radio
as a kind of bombardment
for sending the same
message out to millions,
here's the surround.
This is the Family of
Man exhibition in 1955.
And you can see that people are
free to move, free to aggregate
as they want to.
They can look at the
images that matter
to them, which will be
at all different heights
and all different sizes.
And they are free in that space.
But I think we can also
see-- and this is right
to your point--
that this represents a
new mode of media power.
It's a mode of media power
that we inhabit today.
So the old mode
of media power was
imagined as mad political
leaders screaming down
through a single pipe being
heard by millions all at once.
But when we look at the
Family of Man exhibition,
we can see something that
the people who are visiting
the exhibition cannot.
We can see the backstage.
We can see that this environment
has been carefully arranged
for them.
It's been carefully
chosen for them.
I dare say, it's a choice
architecture in a lot of ways.
And there are people behind
the scenes building that choice
architecture, which
people may experience
as freeing and liberating.
But which also offers
certain kinds of constraints.
And this is where we are today.
This is the hard thing.
This is the 2010 consumer
electronics show in Las Vegas.
And it's a precise imitation
of a later Herbert Bayer
environment.
This aesthetic,
this form, this idea
that we can manage best
and free people most
by building architectures within
which they will make choices
from an array that
we have provided,
that idea arises during
World War II as an effort
to defeat the forces of fascism
and the forces of mass media
that we thought at
the time were aligned.
So we're beginning
to be in the present.
And I just want to
say for a second
that we still have a problem.
One problem is the
Orwell problem.
The building a system to
constrain and contain.
And you know, when people feel
free but don't act that way,
they can end up in
all kinds of trouble.
There's another problem, though.
It's the Trump problem.
Whatever you think of
Donald Trump's policies,
you can see that he is
speaking in an idiom borrowed
from the happenings of
the '60s in a lot of ways.
He's very emotional.
He's very expressive.
He's very free.
He says whatever's on his mind.
And the fact that we have
a distributed global media
system doesn't, in fact,
interfere with that.
Because instead,
it sort of cycles
on to other media forms,
other media platforms.
This is the challenge,
ladies and gentlemen.
We have transformed our
understanding of media power.
We have, in many ways, left
the mess media world behind.
I would argue that
we have not yet
figured out how
to make this world
work, which is why it's so
exciting to be speaking here
today.
That's what I've got, and
I'll open it up to questions.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
If you guys wouldn't mind,
we have a mic in the back.
FRED TURNER: Great.
AUDIENCE: So advertising
is, of course, a hot topic
here in Silicon Valley.
It pays all our
salaries in this room.
How do these principles
apply to/differ
from modern advertising?
FRED TURNER: Yeah,
great question OK.
So the question is
really about advertising.
Advertising is such an
interesting and tricky
business.
I think in many ways, folks
have at different times
in the commercial
sector sought to build
advertising environments that
would serve as precisely choice
architectures.
What's interesting about the
democratic surround piece
is that that choice
architecture was originally
a totally politicized
concept and only later became
a commercialized one.
In the '40s and early
'50s, the people
who were building these
environments really
saw them as not anti-commercial,
but not commercial.
They were there to help
people appreciate difference
from one another.
Over time, that
politics disappeared
and you ended up
in the late '50s
at Moscow in 1959 bringing
both this display mode
and all kinds of consumer goods.
My own view on this--
I'll just speak my own view,
is that it's a very mixed bag.
On the one hand, I get
frustrated in living
in a constantly
commercialized environment.
It really frustrates me.
I would like to be able
to leave that behind.
On the other hand, I'm aware
that through those commercials,
I see not only an
array of products,
but an array of different
ways of living and being
that might not otherwise
be available to me.
I guess the last thing,
I have to get back
to Orwell for just
a minute, right?
The scary thing is if you can do
the thing that I think you all
may be able to do to some
degree, which is predict
the desire of the consumer
before the consumer quite
has the desire, and offer
the product that triggers
the desire, then
we're entering a space
that's a little bit different
than what these folks imagined.
And I'm starting to
be a little nervous.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
FRED TURNER: Sure,
you're welcome.
I hope that's useful.
I'm curious-- let me
ask you a question.
Do you see yourselves
in this story at all,
or does it feel
like something just
from a really different era?
I'm very curious.
Yeah, go for it.
AUDIENCE: I mean, this
definitely connects
with a lot of what we
think about in terms
of ecosystem design.
We're constantly
having conversations
about opt-in versus opt-out.
FRED TURNER: Interesting.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And the tracking
thing at like the Moscow Expo,
that reminds me a lot of
on online advertising,
you can track how often people
clicked or stuff like that.
FRED TURNER: Right.
AUDIENCE: It reminds me of
like an analog version of that.
FRED TURNER: Yeah.
I think it's very much an
analog version of that.
And I actually think that on
the tracking side in particular,
there are digital people who are
going to design the computing
systems that will
eventually become where we
are now who are at this event.
And for them, I
think that tracking
and pro-democratic activity
are not seen as opposites.
Orwell hasn't written yet.
It's really like, no.
We're just going to do this.
It make sense.
That that's very interesting.
Part of my goal,
just as a historian,
is to try to provide
context to think
about things in the present.
And no one has any time to
really read up on the past,
I get that.
But it's also like,
this stuff is present.
Other things that connect
or don't connect here?
I'd be very curious.
Yeah, go for it.
AUDIENCE: I'm an engineer here
at Google, so a former classics
major.
And I noticed you were throwing
around the word "democracy"
very frequently, as if
democracy was an artistic style.
But that doesn't jive at
all with my understanding
of what the word means.
FRED TURNER: Great.
AUDIENCE: It's not
an artistic style.
It's a way of making decisions.
FRED TURNER: Great.
AUDIENCE: And so the way you
arrange paintings in a room
has nothing to do with
making decisions at all.
So I am very
skeptical of the claim
that any artistic
style is democratic.
FRED TURNER: Great.
AUDIENCE: In particular,
artistic happenings.
If you take away all
structure all together,
that is not democratic.
That's the opposite [INAUDIBLE].
FRED TURNER: Totally agree.
OK.
So you and I are
actually, completely--
I'm going to just
repeat the critique.
Can you hear the
questions and comments OK?
SPEAKER 1: You can repeat it.
FRED TURNER: OK, great.
I'll repeat it.
So the critique in
a nutshell is I'm
talking about
aesthetics as if they
were democratic and democracy.
Democracy is not an aesthetic.
It is, instead, a way
of making decisions.
And some of the
environments that I've
described as
democratic-like happenings
are, in fact, anything
but democratic.
Fair summary?
OK, great.
I totally agree with you.
And this is one of those things
where in my presentation,
I've perhaps been too slippery.
What I'm trying to
give you a feel for is
what my subjects
thought was going on.
They did believe that these
were democratizing activities.
They did believe that if
you got the architecture
of an aesthetic space
right, it would then
be possible to make a
new kind of decision.
Their logic.
And I'm just repeating them.
I'm not saying that
this is true or not.
But these are America's leading
psychologists of the time.
People like Gordon
Allport at Harvard.
It's leading anthropologist
Margaret Mead.
They really think that the way
democratic decisions get made
depends on the state
of your personality.
You need to be oriented
toward collaboration,
oriented towards
sharing with others.
You can't be an authoritarian.
You can't be trying to dominate.
So before you can
make proper decisions,
you have to get a
personality oriented
toward the possibility of
democratic-style collaboration.
How do you do that?
You do it first in the family
as you raise the child up.
But then with adults, you
build media environments
in which they can rehearse the
perceptual and psychological
conditions that they will
be needing to use when it
comes to decision-making time.
So Mead wrote a great paper,
which I really recommend,
called--
it has the world's
most boring title,
so no one's ever read it.
But it's called "The
Small Conference."
And it's all about exactly
the thing that you describe.
It's about, how do
you build a room
and build interaction styles
that will promote a personality
style that will in turn lead
to democratic decision-making?
Your critique is exactly right.
So when I went to the
happenings in particular,
I was really surprised.
I was always told, these are
the most democratizing things
to ever hit American theater.
I got it in there.
On the contrary, they were
authoritarian wonderlands.
Almost all white men.
Women in the shows tended
to be depicted either naked
or under wet sheets.
They were horribly misogynistic.
All of the kind of liberating
politics of the '40s were gone.
I had no idea of this.
In the '40s, radical anti-racist
critique in America said look,
we can't be like the Nazis.
We can't do the racist
things they're doing.
We have to be different.
Also, a radical argument
for sexual diversity,
sexual preference diversity,
which I didn't even know
existed.
I thought the closet ran right
up until 1969 and Stonewall.
On the contrary, it
turns out that there
were people writing in '49,
in '48 and '50 saying, look.
No, we need to open this up.
We need to become
a diverse America.
Those critiques have
melted away by the time
we get to the happenings.
And the happenings without
structure are precisely,
I would argue, anti-democratic.
Just right there with you.
Yeah.
Great.
I'm just going to repeat
the question for the record.
So the question is, in
a curated environment
in which every
selection that you make
is nudged and shaped in
a particular direction.
Not completely determined,
but nudged and shaped.
And in which your behavior
is constantly monitored,
is that really any freer?
So I'm assuming you
meant by "better,"
is that really any freer
than the mass media world?
And if you'd ask me that
question 10 years ago,
I would have said
yes, absolutely,
because people have
some degree of choice.
If you asked me that question
today, I'd have to say no.
I find myself strangely
filled with a longing
for Walter Cronkite.
You know Walter
Cronkite, the newscaster?
I was raised in the era
of centralized media.
We had three TV
stations in my family.
In my town where we lived.
And as a scholar, I was
raised to critique that.
I was raised to say, centralized
media, centralized control
produces monolithic opinions.
And that's bad.
What I see now, on the
contrary, is radically dispersed
opinions, archipelagos
of opinion.
Many islands everywhere
producing a kind
of chaotic lack of order.
A kind of chaotic
lack of an ability
to make a decision
because we don't
share the same information.
So not only am I bothered
by the power of those
who curate and monitor.
I'm bothered by the ways
in which the individuation
of experience through media
makes it more difficult to come
to democratic consensus.
So I'm bothered on both counts.
Great.
So let me rephrase the question.
You're asking a really
important question.
And if my sociology
friends were here,
they'd be so happy to hear it.
Because you're asking
about what my field
would call ideological work.
Do we need to do
more ideological work
to promote a civic
vision that is
different than the one we have?
And particularly, do
we need to promote
a civic vision, something
like the European Union's
work together, making it
visible to ordinary folks
so that they can buy-in
to it, rather than try
to exit through Brexit?
Absolutely.
I really think so.
One of the things that
I fault Facebook with--
and some parts of Google, but
more Facebook is promoting
the notion that all we need
to be a healthy civic group
is more individualized
expression.
If you talk to sort of Mark
Zuckerberg and the people
right around him--
and I know he's easier
to pick on here than he would
be at the next town over.
I get that.
And there's a lot I admire
at Facebook, as there
is a lot I admire here.
But if you talk to some of those
folks in the middle, I think--
middle of their
operation, you'll
hear that they genuinely
believe that connecting people
produces a more
democratic world.
That we need to expose
one another to one
another's views
and simply connect.
We need to realize as the
poster from the '60s has it
that we are all one.
I'm here to tell you that is
insufficient for democracy.
That tends to produce
echo chambers.
It tends to produce
worlds where we
hang with those like ourselves.
The challenge of
democracy-- and this
is the ideology I would promote
if it were mine to promote.
The challenge of
democracy is not
to become more expressive
among those who already agree.
It's to learn to work together
across lines of difference.
How do you work with folks who
are very different than you?
How do you make that happen?
And how do you
build institutions
that distribute resources across
differences so that people
who don't have a lot get more?
People who have
more can give more?
And you can actually
collaborate?
That's the ideology
I would promote.
I would use the word "civic."
I think the word "civic"
is under-utilized.
I love the word "democracy."
I think it's been beaten
down a little bit, so I
use the word "civic" a
lot when I try to think
about a civic ideology.
Yeah.
Right.
That's right.
It's not incompatible.
And I very much
admire these folks.
In fact, I almost
can't write a book
unless I'm really pretty partly
in love with the people in it.
I thought for a
while, for example,
of doing a biography
of Buckminster Fuller.
And I got about
five months in and I
realized he was just
a horrible person,
and I couldn't spend
more time with him.
And I felt bad because it's
a really important book.
Somebody should write it.
But I couldn't do it.
But no, I think Margaret Mead
is somebody I really love.
And you know, she
back in the '40s
had a saying that I think
applies right at this moment.
She said, "Were the world
we dream of attained,
members of that new world would
be so different from ourselves
that they would
no longer value it
in the same terms in
which we now desire it.
We would no longer be
at home in such a world.
We who have dreamed it
could not live in it."
I think we live in her world.
I think we live in the legacy
of the ideological turn
that she promoted.
I'm still partway in
love with that ideology,
even as I know that it's brought
us things that maybe challenge
the values that underlie it.
Yeah, go for it.
That's a great question.
So the question was, am I aware
of the sort of long commentary
forums that are
emerging on YouTube now
with folks like Jordan Peterson,
sort of dark web model,
and how rich and how
thick that commentary
is as distinct from mass
media commentary, which
has gotten thinner and thinner?
Did I get that OK?
Yeah.
I'm not aware of that,
and I need to be.
I've heard of it.
I haven't watched it.
I think watching it is key.
I have a problem.
As somebody who does a
lot of historical work,
I have a time problem.
I've watched with the web.
I've been studying
things connected
to the web since the early '90s.
I've watched things come
and go with great ferocity.
And so I'm very slow
to react to stuff.
I have friends who
are always telling me,
you need to try this, try that.
Some things, like
Reddit, stick around.
Other things, like
Myspace, not so much.
And so I haven't seen
that yet, but I want to.
I've been struck by the
high-quality small-forum
commentary that I get.
For example, on
Twitter I can often
get very good, high-quality
small-forum content
from experts.
I'm also struck by the
great sea of sort of almost
information that's out there.
And I haven't found
much in between.
YouTube's a great case.
My daughter learned how
to do makeup from YouTube.
She learned from
a makeup comedian.
It was great.
But I think that's fascinating.
I'll be very curious
to see where that goes.
Yeah, great.
Go for it.
Yeah.
So is quantum consciousness
and the new spirituality
the antidote to what
I'm showing here?
No, on the contrary.
So I've spent a lot of time with
tech folks for a lot of time.
The mode of spirituality that
you're describing, I think,
is widely shared in the tech
community and not as widely
shared elsewhere in my view.
And I would argue that the mode
of spirituality that you're
describing is particular--
it supports basically a new
elite, a new aristocracy.
I'll go even farther
and say that there
are modes of behavior that
are available to people who
are super-smart,
super-scientific,
and super-well-funded that
are not available to others.
Polyamory is one.
It's available to
others, but it's
something that requires
a kind of coordination,
collaboration sense of
support that's not available.
Certain modes of spirituality
are in touch with that.
I'm struck by the
difference between that mode
of spirituality and Baptist
churches in the South.
Really distinct.
I'm not saying that
that's bad at all.
On the contrary, I'm
fascinated by it.
But I think it's distinct.
And I think there are
modes of spirituality as
distinct from
organized religion that
are emerging that support a
kind of very individuated, very
tech-savvy, smart kind of life
that you can live if you have
all the resources that you would
need to be able to do those
things.
That would be my--
I also do [INAUDIBLE].
I'm glad that you
asked about rhythms.
Because of course,
that vision has
been around tech worlds
a lot in the past.
The spirituality that you
described animated CW Post.
I don't know if you
eat Post Cereals,
but CW Post was the inventor
of Post Grape-Nuts and the Post
brand.
And he believed precisely
in the kind of spirituality
that you're describing and
a slightly different version
of it.
But he believed
that natural foods
were one of the keys
to maintaining that.
He built a whole
community around it.
There were other groups,
like the Oneida group
in 19th century
upstate New York,
who saw that-- or
the Fourierists.
I mean, there's a whole series
of kind of groups like that.
And sometimes, I wonder
when I walk the campus here,
and particularly when I
see some of your colleagues
in communes where they live or
in new spiritual communities
that they participate
in, which I do.
I sometimes wonder if they
are the new Fourierists,
the new Oneidas.
I don't know.
It's a question.
It's a great question,
I just don't know.
Yeah, I think the answer is no.
I think that you cannot
have a democratic society
if the people who are making the
decisions about the direction
of the society don't
share the same facts.
And the way that we've
managed that traditionally
in democratic
societies I think is
through an elite that
would be in charge
of certain kinds of facts.
You would be an economic expert.
You would be a technical expert.
You would be a social expert.
Those folks get together
and make decisions
and are informed by various
bits of news from down below.
And in turn, send it back
through the mass media.
Here, we can all agree on this.
In the current condition, that's
not happening very effectively.
And no, I think it's
very difficult to have
a democracy in that space.
I'm hoping that we can
agree on fact again.
I think it's no accident that
democracy and science tend
to rise and fall together.
Yeah, we need facts badly.
Great.
OK.
Thank you all very
much for having me.
I appreciate your taking an
hour out of your day to be here.
And it's great to be doing--
if you're a historian,
you spend a lot of time alone
in your room with the past.
It's so nice to be
out talking to folks
in the present about the
things that you study.
Thanks for having me.
Appreciate it.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you, Fred.
Thank you, everybody,
for coming.
[APPLAUSE]